[Music]
70% of the people they don't believe our
government tells me the truth and that's
really good because they aren't telling
us the truth
some kids smoking a joint goes to prison
and treated monstrously doesn't history
Templars that marijuana has been used as
medication for thousands of years but
what if a doctor says hey run it's not a
bad idea for you to start smoking weed
would you do it so today we're in the
office of dr. Ron Paul if you don't
recognize this face he ran for president
multiple times once he ran back in 1988
as a libertarian hi and they you ran in
oh wait and 2012 as a Republican and an
interesting fact about the way he ran
his campaign when the internet was just
coming up nobody was doing a lot of
campaigning through the internet and his
concept and beliefs that he had as a
libertarian wasn't yet accepted by a lot
of different people he went out in the
first 24 hours in a 24 hour period
campaigning only on the Internet raised
six million dollars at a time when
nobody was raising money and then you
hear about Obama's doing that on all
these other guys doing about he was a
myspace guy a YouTube guy in his 70s and
his audience were twenty year olds
eighteen year olds all over college
campuses similar to what Bernie Sanders
did recently Bernie Sanders many say
took a page out of his playbook in the
marketing campaign that he had when he
ran for office so here we go dr. Ron
Paul thank you good to be here with you
appreciate thank you for making the time
by the way the more and more I study you
and find out about you juicier
philosophies are very interesting today
I would like to address a few different
issues one is your book and the Fed I'm
always fascinated by economy I'd like to
talk to you about marijuana I know you
have some strong beliefs about marijuana
see where you stand about that and I
have a fun challenge for you I'm curious
in if you'll take that challenge you
you're probably thinking what the
challenges we'll get into that part a
little bit of the IRS a little bit of
Trump a little bit that stuff in an
obviously part of your story so before
we get into those issues I was talking
to you earlier you were saying you were
raising a family Pittsburgh five kids
you're the middle kid and you're coming
up I know you wanted to the air force I
know you know to being a doctor I know
you delivered over 4,000 babies so the
typical person that runs for office is
normally and it's
you are not the typical one neither you
or your son Rand Paul also ran for
office when did the inspiration come for
you to say I'd like to one day enter
politics never happened to me but I was
inspired to try to promote a message and
talk about a message so the first time I
decided to speak out in a political
sense was in 1974 which was a Watergate
year Republicans were dead in the war
lot water nobody wanted to run at that
time Texas had three Republicans now we
are like 35 you know congressman so it
was all Democrats so there was a whole
Texas yes so there was a void there and
then the Republicans were just starting
to you know the shift from Democrat
conservative Democrat to Republican so I
thought well you know I'm going I'm
gonna speak out because I was exposed to
Austrian free-market economics and the
Mises high act type of approach and I
was convinced they were on the right
track and I was convinced also that
nobody in Washington ever heard of them
so I thought well I need to talk about I
want to get that message out so I went
to my wife and I was very very busy
practicing love medicine still I never
disliked medicine I never said I'm gonna
give up medicine I'm going into politics
and so I told my wife I want to run for
office in the 70s is when when the
Bretton Woods broke down and we had
inflation of 15% and interest rates a
21-foot that was really exciting stuff
and very very dangerous I wanted to talk
about because they harder era yes well
no that would pre cause that's right
that's why Ford was in office - it was
it was said through the Watergate years
and we had Nixon era but it was very
very exciting but very very dangerous so
I went to my wife I said look I want to
talk about this she'd what are you gonna
do I said I'm gonna run for Congress
she'll what in the world with you I had
no expectation Lex you have no idea
you're gonna be doing this no this was
my introduction to her to tip her off
would well you know I was planning to do
and I say she says well this could be
very dangerous
I said why would it be dangerous she
said you could get elected I guaranteed
her totally impossible that's not my
goal my goal is just to reach a few
people
said you said there's no money you know
I told her it's not gonna work and she
and she's totally non-political a little
more political now than she was then
because all she wanted to do is raise
the kids and and and be a wife and you
also had five kids yes right so she she
said no she said you're gonna win I said
no no I'm not gonna be Santa Claus I'm
not passing this I I want to tell people
they have to work for a living you know
the whole philosophy and she says yes
and she said something that's stuck with
me because people have come and thrown
it back at me she says they're going to
like what you say because they're gonna
believe you're telling the truth
and you know in a way that is what I
heard so often and that's why people in
my district would support me they said
we know you're telling the truth we
don't agree with all your libertarian
stuff but we like the idea that you're
telling the truth and you know and I
imagine you have observed at times the
starvation for truth right now just
think of what's going in our politics
nobody knows who's talking about the
truth it's totally boys everybody's a
fake news you know both sides accuse the
others I have fake news so that was why
I got into it but of course it opened up
political goals and sometimes success in
politics has to do with luck you know
being in the right place at the right
time is there a book like did you read a
book like that like who was the I know
you were captain in the military you
were captain in the Air Force and you
were a doctor in the Air Force so you
don't know you weren't around back in
1970 I believe when you were not 1970 I
think even earlier than in the 60s when
you went to Tehran right so I know
you've been all over but was there like
a guy in your ear saying hey Ron read
this book by Hayek hey Ron read this was
there somebody not one person but I
think people and they're one thing I
encourage people that say a graduation
ceremony stay curious
look for the truth it's up to you you
have to go looking for were you a reader
were you always a read that that is what
motivated me to read you know at the
time and then I would look around and I
came across the foundation for economic
education and that was Leonard Reid's
group it was he one of them you always
talk about Leonard Reid
yeah you're a big fan of Leno really he
was in New York so I got to know him but
he provided books
I would buy the books through them no
internet you know the names Mises and
got his books and kayak and Rothbard and
san hold so I was really fascinated with
Austrian economics so my motivation in
those years was to study and to
understand one philosophy that I Leonard
read taught me he says don't worry about
what you're gonna do look for the truth
and if you've become knowledgeable he
said somebody will seek you out and
somebody will use you don't worry about
the plan no plans
somebody's gonna seek you out of
somebody yeah one of the most pleasant
things that ever happened to me
every once in a while an individual
would come another congressman I'd be up
there and voting all by myself I don't
know whether you noticed there was a
time when I voted by myself quite
frequently and he knew I wasn't you know
a loudmouth trying to demagogue anything
they would come and sit down said Ron
why are you doing this it doesn't make
any said you're either not voting with
anybody or you're voting sometimes with
the Liberals but it was a sincere
question and I explained them briefly
the philosophy and it's and those
several were converted you know over
because that's the key portion is the
key well to influence and to have them
be curious and then for them to study it
another example that I just loved was
with Walter Jones you know I follow up a
foreign policy of non-intervention ISM
and he felt like he was lied about the
Iraq war and it upset him a whole lot
and he voted for it and he saw what
happened he voted for yeah anyway he's
punishing himself still about that but
he came and we had a lot of conversation
he turned that priori my closest friend
in Washington but he went from you know
just going with conventional wisdom of
the hawkish Republicans and all of a
sudden he say
hey you know there's something more to
it than this so that pleased me a whole
lot 1974 was media as influential as it
is today did they have that much
influence because I remember the first
debate that was a national debate on
television was when Nixon was doing it
off radio because it used to be Radio
Nixon did well but once there was TV
Kennedy Excel because Kennedy did well
on TV but Nixon didn't so
was this one America
was kind of transitioning into the power
of media was it barely getting into it
oh well that was in the 16 where they
had where Nixon lost you know to Kennedy
no it was a transition gradually you
know and the debates would be have occur
they used TV ever you know ever since
the Nixon debate but it changed things a
whole lot that is when they introduced
television recordings of us on the House
floor and I said I've never voted for a
government program but I voted to put
the cameras they need to see what we're
doing but that sort of backfired because
everybody spoke to the cameras you know
they knew how to handle that public
relations so how much did a politics
when you look at the politics and I see
somebody talk and I say okay this person
makes sense what they're saying but
they're not a good salesperson that
person doesn't make a lot of sense but
they're a good salesperson this person
makes zero sense but they're a great
salesperson and they know how to play
the game of politics
how important is selling and learning
how to play the game of politics of
pinning against each other and not
taking a lot personally I mean I see
that being a big strength of Trump how
big of an influence do you think those
two other parts are as well well yes
it's what what you're going life is you
know if you're going life has to be a
congressman you do things completely
different then then what I did young
people now when I go to the college
campuses they'll still come up and I say
you understand what you're saying
what am I supposed to do and you know
how can I go to medical school and then
go to Congress and all I say
I said if that's your goal forget it it
shouldn't be your goal you know it's
back to education I don't believe the
politicians who make these plans and lay
the plans and join the parties and
become a precinct worker and work your
way up and learn how to raise money and
go to the professionals you're not a fan
of that you know I think I think that's
the way it's done I think it's wrong and
that's why the wrong people go I think
it also ought to be a more issue
oriented so if somebody comes up I don't
like the demagogues the noisy stuff but
if somebody comes up and they're very
serious and they say Ron I disagree we
do because I'm a socialist and we can
one person that was close to that was
Barney
Frank Barney Frank and I got along real
well and we had a lot of disagreement
but we had a lot of greement because he
was a progressive and we'd agree on
civil liberties and we did legislation
on on drugs how we regulate that and
some on foreign policy
it was the issues that counted more than
anything else but I think most people go
in because they want to be a congressman
I think you should want to change
people's views to me that's the only
thing that counts remember we have is a
reflection of the prevailing attitudes
of the people so I'm more interested in
changing the attitudes of the people and
understanding why Liberty can be
defended rather than saying oh I need
help you know I might be out of work
and people are poor in this country and
this is why we need authoritarians to go
to Washington take money from this group
and take care of everybody else and
teach you what your private personal
habits ought to be I just refuse to
accept that approach if you really
believe Liberty is possible today and
here's what I mean by Liberty there's
two different ways right one of them is
conceptually so it's good for us to keep
talking about it because at least the
right concepts will stick but will we
ever have full Liberty we'll probably
guys let's face it we're never gonna
have it but let's keep talking about all
this other stuff are you coming from
we'll play stuff out of no I fully
believe in Liberty is possible in
America
oh yeah well a Liberty is to some degree
but perfect Liberty I mean mankind is
not perfect so define Liberty what does
Liberty and libertarian mean to you I
know it to me is one thing on that
subject of perfect Liberty versus
perfect communism you know it just
doesn't exist but the goal should be
Liberty so for me to pursue what I have
been doing for these many decades is
that I have to have a definition what do
you mean by livery why is it important
to you is this is this a social belief
in economic belief or religious believer
you know what is it I have come to the
conclusion that the most important issue
or rule that should guide our lives is
something that has been universal and I
think we're making progress matter of
fact I think that we can do a lot better
and we're in a move and there's a lot of
reason why I'm an optimist but it's
based on a concept which is called
non-aggression you can't commit
aggression and it's very simply
don't lie don't cheat don't steal don't
hurt people and don't kill people but
all the great religions endorse these
things if everybody did that can you
imagine how much more peaceful the world
be the man is fragile and they aren't
man kindness they're not perfect so they
will always get away from that the big
question is is do you want the
authoritarian government people who want
to be in control send them to Washington
to make sure that you're a better person
that doesn't work because then the
monopolies use of aggression and control
is given to the government you know in
and and the ruled it follows this is if
you and I have disagreement okay you
know I agree with your honor I'm not
gonna steal from you and I'm not gonna
hurt you I'm not gonna kill you and all
these things but all of a sudden
government's exempt from these rules the
government lies to us they cheat they
counterfeit the money we go off around
the world we're gonna police the world
we killed people we can't we drop a bomb
every 12 minutes right now on foreigners
it's just totally out of control because
the governments don't obey the rules and
but people don't address that they keep
saying put me in office I'm a dedicated
right winger and I want to be in there
and have my rules when somebody else
comes go no I'm compassionate and I will
steal the money from this group and give
it this group and I will create perfect
equality for everybody well they ought
to think about equality under in the
justice system is what they ought to
concentrate on but I think the
government always reflects the
prevailing attitude of the people and
therefore politicians have a lot to say
about that but they're very unimportant
they're very very unimportant
politicians are very honorable very
unimportant overall long term Mises is
more important than nobody's ever heard
of but if you want to move to a freer
economy and understand for instance
right now we're being challenged with
this notion of tariffs
I'm really pretty shocked about the
support tariffs are getting but it's a
misunderstanding of economic policy but
the prevailing attitude should be that
people have a right to buy and sell
their goods and services
and that is what free markets teach but
the people get the government they
deserve in many ways sometimes it's hard
to get rid of a bad government but the
government right now reflects a
philosophy of interventionism a planned
economy inflation ISM central banking
social welfare program policing the
world you say well that sounds like
you're against the Democrat oh no maybe
you're against the Republican they're
both the same
there's too much I've seen Republicans
and Democrats are the same in many ways
philosophically the basic philosophy is
the same they believe in intervention
they just have different management
styles they might pick out well we want
to redistribute the wealth I want this
group you want this group so but they
endorsed intervention ISM maybe
enforcing government power and that's
what has to be challenged I got a
question for you then so you ran in 1988
as a libertarian right in
oh wait and 2012 you ran as a republican
why didn't you run as a libertarian
again in oh wait in 2012 to change the
game instead of running as a republican
yourself well a lot more people heard of
me 12 than they did in 1988 as a
marketing marketing strategy parties
mean very little to me even though I'm a
lifetime member of the Libertarian Party
I've spent all my political career as a
Republican it doesn't matter the simpler
it is a concept like you look at Trump
Rand Trump said what make America great
again right it resonated it was a simple
campaign and people were just fed up
with politicians when Obama ran Obama
was what dream or change right what are
we changing I don't know what we're
changing so voters are like this is cool
let's change this is cool let's make
America great again do you think
partially the challenge with the
libertarian concept is the fact that the
message is being delivered by such super
smart intelligent guys like you like
Peter Schiff like some of these guys
that people are sitting there saying it
kind of makes sense but man I'm having a
hard time understanding this talk to me
as if I'm a sixth grade you know level
four okay we're say that could be a
reason well what I I think you're not
emphasizing is there's been tremendous
changed to get this message out that is
that was truly agree yeah I just think
of the progress we've made and you even
mention it in the introduction the
internet helped me six million in 24
hours this I mean it's fantastic the
people that you reach you can change
things because you're changing people's
minds but if you're saying well you got
it if you join the crowd and say well
anybody about trumple we got to get rid
of this trumpet he's real evil this kind
of stuff and in that that is all
political chicanery but it has to be
philosophic which is not easy but that's
where the progress is made when I went
to Washington 76 nobody ever heard of
Mises or the Federal Reserve needed
auditing right I mean it did the early
on I live in a Bible Belt district and I
took a position on the drug war no drug
war it's evil it's monstrous
prohibitions don't work and get rid of
it and I thought well there goes by
they're not gonna reelect me now and I
thought that came up when I was out and
went back in again but they never held
it against me
because because the idea was out there
but they were afraid to say it so many
families had already been hurt because
of some kids smoking a joint goes to
prison and treated monstrously in here
now they're saying you know it doesn't
history tell us that marijuana has been
used as medication for thousands of
years why don't we think about using
again just yesterday it was announced
that we might use it and that's
ideological and I figure you might say
back in 88 Ron you talked about drugs
all that what good did you do you've
talked about it you know in your
congressional campaign you talked about
in the presidential campaign
but all of a sudden you know we did it I
can I consider it a great victory I
think it's a massive progress you would
a face of libertarian for a long I mean
you made a lot of progress
some people will give you more credit
than some of the other guys that
originally started it because you got
the message across the board and the
toughest part with you will have so much
respect for you is you were able to
connect with an audience that others had
such a hard time getting to the younger
audience and a message dad I mean look
at the media today you would
soon if the left the Liberals the left
the Democrats control what percentage of
the media matter of fact let me ask it
the other way around what media platform
today in America is right outside of Fox
knows what else is right outside right
wing you may like wing yeah see I don't
think in right and left I think an
authoritarian and non authoritarian
they're all authoritarians you know just
about everybody ELISA fees to to talk
about conservative economic philosophies
that is not going to be on the Left
that's going to be on the right to talk
about constantly giving up social
programs just because let's tax people
higher yeah that's a fiction that
Republicans are better than the
Democrats on that the Republicans are
the ones who have introduced the
legislation to increase government
control and abuse of the medical care
system oh no it was Obamacare you know
that sort of thing but previously one
time the vote that took the longest in
while I was there maybe in history it
lasts about it ten hours they had to
pass prescription drug program and
because it was a Republican thing it was
Bush and we stayed up till 3:00 in the
morning you know until they got the
votes to support the drug dealer I'm
well they are drug dealers the drug
industry's it's run by corporations
that's release a drug dealer that's so
funny they're dealing in abuse I'll tell
you because they're at the FDA then
they're in big drug companies and all
someone's getting paid yes different
they have different people are
supporting it's it's fair to say you
even said it earlier when we're
off-camera CNBC when Tucker was there
before he got fired when he supported
you in the 2008 convention that you guys
had with Jesse Ventura all these other
guys I showed up is it fair to say that
if you were to say MSNBC CNN you know
Time magazine money magazine fortune
some of these magazines some of these
platforms are leaning more towards a
higher tax rate and maybe Fox is gonna
say let's be a little bit more limited
government on the lower end yeah I think
you're putting an important thing
because intervention can go either way
intervention can be bad or good but it's
the intervention that I want to to
challenge sure but your supports Bush
initially when it came out you were kind
of
little bit optimistic about what he was
gonna do until all of a sudden the
government started getting bigger and
bigger and he hired more right the
limited government became Wow are you
sure talking about george w bush bush
well i think the strongest statement I
ever could have made was he used to say
in the campaign that we should have a
humble foreign policy and that we
shouldn't be policing the world you know
his his statement was thrown out there
to appeal to a few of us and I thought
well maybe but Trump does that too okay
so you're saying let's find the truth
fair I want to find the truth you found
out the truth because you talked to
Leonard Reid and Leonard Reid gave you
these books that he would say he read
this read that and you went through it
and then he said if you keep talking to
truth eventually someone's gonna notice
you and they're gonna find a way to use
you fair enough so if you're saying that
then what is the truth and how can I a
naive 22 year old a naive 18 year old 27
year old 38 year old who's never paid
attention to politics I was a former
military guy now I'm starting to realize
I'm paying a lot of taxes life is
getting expensive why is this President
Donald Trump he makes no sense this guy
used to be in business I like him I
don't like him some people hate him some
people love them where do I get my
source of the truth well a lot of people
aren't ever going to pay any attention
you have to think about the way the
world works is their thought leaders the
people who run the television companies
there are people who write books to
people who have programs on the air
their persuasions are very very
important and people have to have a
basic understanding of what they believe
in and if they don't have that they
can't hone in on on how to handle
interventionism you if you endorse the
fact that government should have this
power and authority to run our life
police the world tell us what to do and
you know run everything then you say
well we just need better leaders we just
need to clean up the mess we don't want
the you know the loafers to get on you
know that sort of thing it isn't a
management problem it's a philosophic
problem on whether or not the government
has the right to use guns to
redistribute wealth and everybody in
Washington except for about five people
believe that they endorse that principle
sure it varies about the tax code I read
just yesterday that it said that this
tax code which
you know sounded like I couldn't vote it
for it cause it lowered lower taxes but
there was there was one vote they just
discovered oh they're raising taxes in
this area so it's it's intervention and
I think the argument ought to be does
the government have the moral authority
to intervene in your personal life to
tell you how you run should run your
personal life and your social life or
your religious life the answer should be
no but we take that that answer and
apply it to economics and say should the
government you know sort it out so that
there's more equality and that everybody
has you know being taken care of nobody
fails in this sort of thing and and the
libertarian says it doesn't work it
bankrupts the country it's done by force
and the people who use it an extreme
point are the people in Venezuela you
know and it doesn't work and this is
where we are today we are totally
bankrupt because there's been too much
concession because people want to be
humane and say you can't just throw
people out on the street is that a
Republican principle or democratic
principle what on handouts
oh it's bipartisan everything is
bipartisan you're saying you're saying
handouts is bipartisan is the welfare
state produced under Oregon party and a
lot of big programs Republican so your
opinion okay so how about we go one by
one by one marijuana
what's your beliefs on marijuana should
it be legal should I not be legal well
it should be decriminalized it should be
no criminal penalties for using
marijuana and that's clear-cut you have
a right to do with your life in your
body that you want
and up until 1938 it was legal so it's
just this not up until 1938 whoo yeah oh
that is when they put a tax on it and
they knew they weren't a lot of
regulated because when they want to
regulate booze beer and alcohol yeah
they had amended constitutions to put it
in your food when they would give to
military guys you know joint used to be
in there that guys used to smoke back in
the days and you're a 1935 guy so you're
saying marijuana should be legal not
criminalized absolutely I mean it's
you're sort of asking is who should
protect you from yourself and nobody in
a libertarian society not protect you
from yourself because your habits maybe
the problem you might eat poorly you
might take stuffing in my smoke and do
all these things and governments cannot
do that once you do that you give up
your liberties so you always aim for the
purity of a libertarian society where
you're responsible
but in this response and the young
people you wondered why young people
came my way and they cheered me on this
I say you know in a libertarian society
you can do what you want you can smoke
and drink and all this and you can earn
as much money as you want and we're not
going to take the money from you no
taxation but if you screw up you can't
go to the government and I would get a
loud applause on that it was
responsibility freedom and that you are
rewarded why do you think some people
are against the concept of what you're
talking about everybody has that
instinct I think we're all born
libertarians and then when we're too or
a terrible - and we start getting @b
tonight
then we're sent to a government school
which is considered a prison by a lot of
people and it beats it out of us that's
it took me a lot of years to beat the
bad ideas out of my mind from from a
grade school and high school and college
they were all teaching me the wrong
thing and so my challenge was how do I
get rid of those bad ideas and it took
me by any gradual gradual gradual 15 or
20 years but I think that the momentum
is on our side in spite of the ups and
downs you know that we are so so much
better ever smoked marijuana yourself no
are you open to the idea I know I don't
it doesn't attract me a bit so I was
with Kevin Hart the comedian he's a big
comedian he's got 150 million followers
Kevin Hart said if you're ever gonna
seize never he was never found of
marijuana he said I told my kids the
only person you have the permission to
smoke marijuana with a snoop dog do you
know whose snoop dog yeah I saw it at a
rapper by the way I don't know if you
know or not one time he posted a picture
of yours in his Facebook page and he
said smoke weed every day with your
picture while you were running for
office smoke so if we could arrange it
I don't care he's responsible for his
own life whatever you want so so why
don't you want to smoke marijuana well
why do I not want to eat badly and gain
a lot of weight because you don't think
it's marijuana is good for you well I
have no desire for it and I I don't know
I think that it is not much positive
except I'm not the decider if there's
medicinal plant benefits from it they
what they did was they just legalized
and I find out you know all these kids
have had these severe epileptic fits are
being held
but what if a doctor says hey Ron it's
not a bad idea for you to start smoking
weed would you do it I'm not interested
in it but I I know some people I mean if
you're gonna be forward wouldn't it make
sense for you to try it unlike the 1600s
then I was a better spokesman for for
marijuana than anybody you could find I
MD I didn't use drugs
didn't want my kids using drugs and
that's so different let's say I was
hippies type and didn't they care about
anything else than smoking that turns a
lot of people
oh yeah he just wants to do that they
knew that I was being very upfront I
want to do this for a freedom reason I
want to legalize freedom I don't want to
legalize marijuana
I want to legalize freedom of choice to
run your own life and take your own ribs
I think anything and then you know how
Richard Branson came out and he said I
think heroin should be legal I think all
these other things should be legal is
your argument because marijuana is God
mate and heroin and all the other stuff
is man-made is that kind of the argument
you're making yeah you know and one of
the debates they asked me that question
in the debate because I took the
position you know you legalize heroin so
I said in my answer was it's the
funniest thing in the world this was a
religious conservative crowd is okay
we're gonna legalize heroin Amara I want
to see the hands go up on how many
people are gonna rush out and use heroin
nobody's going to that's not the reason
they do it in the people and making it
the illegal just makes it goes into the
hands of the drug dealers so it's all
the negative things come from from the
regulation of allows people take all
their own risk so you're not for heroin
becoming
Farren no marijuana yes I said no am i
arguing wrong also
yeah legal that's why I said to the
crowd let's make it legal how many of
you would use it and they said no nobody
was going to use it they answered my
question
legalizing it isn't going to encourage
you can imagine a new country okay Ron
Paul has officially been granted a
million acres of land in a small part of
Australia it's gonna be called Ron Paul
land okay in our case making money and
that's not nice I'm not making fun this
is what I'm saying cuz what I'm trying
to say is you say that what market does
it attract for instance I'm from Iran I
was born and raised in Iran what
attracted to America for us to have 41
million immigrants here is the fact that
they offer capitalism so I'm attracted
to it so I come to a place like this but
that's okay I have an example yes oh
that that situation which you think
would be your implying well there's a
little weird is we've had that at one
time we're where did the founders come
down hard on cocaine or anything it just
existed the drug war actually the real
enthusiasm for the drug war and filling
up our prisons came from the Republicans
in the early 1970s under Nixon he
started this obsessive war on drugs so
yes you have the intervention with the
Republicans on social habits and you
have the Democrats on economic habits
and they both endorsed each other it's
sort of like you know you endorsed my my
deal and I'll endorse sure to you
because that's the way it is on military
there'll be some Democrats it's not too
many anymore to say you know we spend
too much money overseas killing people
but we'll let you do that you
Republicans if you give us more money
for food stamps so ok that's a fair deal
and what does happens to our dad its
skyrocket ok so you're not coming from a
place of what's better what's worse your
argument is who cares if it's gonna be
legal if people are not gonna go out and
use it anyways I care about Liberty you
care about Liberty that's fine I respect
that you can't hurt anybody we're just
an opinion you were doctor what's worse
marijuana alcohol or cigarettes based on
your opinion as a doctor which of those
three is worse for you well it all
depends
I know that I'll give you the answer and
I know
it all depends on how much you use you
know of a guy if a guy smokes a cigar
twice a week you know that's one thing
but all those three I think cigarettes
are more deadly more deadly and what's
second for you would it be alcohol or
marijuana no obviously alcohol so you
putting cigarettes worse then it's
alcohol been marijuana yeah and somebody
might occur so is that alcohol and
cigarettes you know they're combined so
often and give people heart problems and
so what I think overall long-term
society and freedom of choice would have
made a much better use in a controlled
use of marijuana but the market works
pretty well with with alcohol
prohibition was horrible because they
had alcohol and it was very concentrated
very strong and also very contaminated
so when it became legal it was much
safer and matter of fact it was when yet
prohibition you had much more potent
alcohol when you made it legal
you had lower percentage of alcohol and
you could pick a weaker beer and this
other thing markets can handle this
people people aren't idiots this idea
that we have to control people is based
and members of Congress told me it's
based on assuming the people are stupid
and they've told me that they said Ron I
agree with you we shouldn't have to do
this on but people are too stupid
they're not gonna do that I know that if
you're gonna be stupid maybe you'll hurt
yourself but people aren't that stupid
like you that crowd show me
nobody said oh I would use heroin
they're gonna do that yeah it all
depends also what market it was you
spoke to how old they were worth Pross
and you know where are they I would you
know risk and accessibility so okay so
let's talk about the next thing ending
the Fed you wrote a book based on a talk
you gave I think you gave a talk in
Michigan I want to say and you were
talking about the Fed some kids scream
and defend and they start taking out you
know currency and they're ripping it up
and throwing her you know all this other
stuff and it became this revolution type
revolution love behind that was your
campaign Ron Paul revolution and that
led him to you writing the book and the
fat so talk about and the fit because
when I read the book in the Fed it is a
very convincing book if you haven't read
the book and the Fed
no matter how old you are whether you're
a Republican Democrat independent
libertine you don't care about politics
you've got to read the book and defend
oh I want to mention that episode in in
Michigan because what you mentioned
there is a very important point for me
is that I didn't
of course I talked about the Fed and
that was my position but it wasn't so
much that I was up there lecturing the
kids you know what I want to do is end
the Fed all right you people here's a
shout-out in the Fed what shocked me and
the reason I wrote the book then was
they had heard this from other sources
that meant the educational process has
infiltrated the climate they weren't
saying legalized marijuana or something
like they said in the Fed and the Fed so
they were already there and of course
they they probably knew my position but
I thought that it was an encouragement
to me to know the date they already knew
kind of goes back to how you ran for
office which we accidentally kind of
inspired an you tell your wife so it's a
purpose of the book the whole thing is
is I want to end the Fed we got to get
rid of it central banking is bad the
world endorses it fiat money is
counterfeit money it's a source of many
of our problems today all these trade
problems that Trump is harping on it's
it's all related to the monetary system
and it's it's a tremendous amount of
power you can imagine what it would be
like if if you came across a group that
had the printing press and they could
print money but it was really
counterfeit because it wasn't the
government and they would print so much
you usually would destroy the value it
was counterfeiting is so bad the reason
well there's so many reasons first it
allows governments get too big this
arguments going on for a long long time
but in our history it went on with
Jefferson and Hamilton and Hamilton was
for the central bank and regulate and in
control of money and all this and
Jefferson was against it and they had
just gone through the runaway inflation
of the Continental dollar and that's
where this slogan comes not worth a
continental because they destroyed the
Continental dollar by just creating too
many of them so they argued it out and
but nevertheless the Federalists created
the First National Bank which was a
a precursor to a central bank Jefferson
got rid of that and then they put the
second bank of the United States was
introduced it did the same thing and
Andrew Jackson got rid of that because
he didn't trust the bankers banking
control of the money is a powerful
weapon but then again it evolved and to
the point anytime there was a ruling on
whether they have this authority the
courts always ruled in favor of the
counterfeiters the government
counterfeiters yeah
the Constitution is very clear the only
thing that you can use as legal tender
in this country and hasn't been repealed
is gold and silver that's the only thing
that we're a lot of used so we've a
disobey day so it's unconstitutional
it doesn't make good economic sense it's
terrible politics it's it's the reason
why is it terrible politics it or is it
a convincing politics for the majority
when a Bernanke comes out and says you
know quantitative easing and that
concept comes out and people say well
this was used in Japan this was using UK
UK got three hundred eighty billion
Japan's done multiple times you know I
think what you're saying now in the
short term yeah but yeah but all mean
what and what I mean is not good for the
economy but politically it's a good
campaign to run because it's convincing
because in majority how many honestly
like how many people you're watching
this right now I'm really curious I want
you to tweet me and Ron Paul the
following answer do you understand the
concept of quantitative easing if you do
I'm curious to know the reason why I
asked this question is the following
reason so you know how you said too many
times Americans we pull out of trust
into our politicians so my gosh this guy
looks so convincing he's on TV he must
be smart he went to a nice school he's a
so UC Berkeley guy Oman he's a Harvard
guy he must know everything I should
trust him to make all the decisions for
me and we throw a big war light they're
like quantitative easing if you were to
explain quantitative easing in the
simplest way what is quantitative easing
mean to you you know they they have said
that and people do trust a politician
they do lie in a demagogue the issue on
the short run but eventually you know
that the troubles come quantitative
easing just means massive the creation
of money and credit so we had point
eight trillion dollars when the crisis
hit and they took it up to four point
four
trillions and trillions of dollars of
new money well who got the money the
money serves the interests of the
powerful bankers other central banks
around the world who are in trouble
other governments I think they use this
for military reasons it's its secret
that's why the audit is so threatening
to them I concentrated on the audit but
that's when they get hysterical no you
not a lot of look at our books because
this is why when you get into a
financial crisis all this QE when it's
painted and people do they get low
interest rates than they buy houses but
it creates the bubble that inevitably
bursts and when the bubble bursts in
oh wait a no.9 the very wealthy the
banks got bailed on the people who made
all that money on the mortgages they
didn't go to jail you know but guess who
lost their jobs during that time and
lost their houses
it was the average guy it's really and
you know that's right they they claim
the economy it's just right up there
right now there's still a great division
in this country on wealth distribution
those people haven't all recovered
there's any even in LA and see a lot of
this homelessness that what we have done
as a consequence of this brilliant idea
of printing money and one reason was is
the people philosophically believed in
that it wasn't that I'm gonna do this no
they philosophically have been teaching
KZ and economics inflation ism central
banking in our colleges ever since the
depression so we have a challenge that's
when I see a victory where kids are
shouting you know in the Fed what look
at what we're challenging a system that
has been brainwashing our kids for
generation after generation so everybody
that you see at the Fed is going to have
the same position yeah
QE this market as much now they're
tightening this whole thing is they
don't know how much money is necessary
they don't know what interest rate
should be it's all manipulation for
special interests and to pay the bills
like the to keep the military-industrial
complex going and keep the wealth oh so
run this is why I ask you to question at
the beginning when I said you think a
big part of politics is one foundational
beliefs where your true belief
you are a true believer everyone knows
this you just watch you whether I go to
1986 when you were a guess I think 1986
when you run I guess I'm Morton Downey
jr. back in the days and you and him
were going back and forth it was a
little bit sensational versus I watching
the debates i watching the things you
write about you're a true believer fair
enough check Ron Paul's a true believer
the next part is selling you're a good
salesperson so you know how to sell your
concept you need to be because you have
to believe if you believe you can
present you can pitch a good pastor a
good coach a good parent needs to know
how to sell the belief system pass to
the audience but the third one is the
part I asked you and you were kind of
like you don't think that's the way to
go to the top the third part is a game
there is a game to be played there's a
political game that some people play the
game better end up making it to the top
my concern is that somebody's watching
this I've been a part of that for
longest but my mother's family were
communist might outside their
imperialist I didn't do politics because
I was like you know what I don't want to
touch politics because they're all
manipulative that's what I've heard in
my entire life until eventually it was
an interest for it how do i how do I
read between the lines the manipulation
of politicians on both sides to know who
is right
what philosophies right to be pushing
that concept well essentially what
happens in order to see the change is
you and others and this is what's
happening is you just reject all of them
you know all the politicians are saying
well no we don't we don't need this guy
as head of the Federal Reserve we need
this guy no we need to get rid of the
Federal Reserve so you have to join the
group now 68 70 percent of the people
they don't believe our government tells
them the truth and that's really good
because they aren't telling us the truth
and they say well you know there'll be a
tragedy there'll be 9/11 there'll be
Kennedy assassination there'll be
another thing we'll have a commission
but the Commission is set up and they
lie to us now you know the Kennedy
Commission I think it's like 80% of
American people don't believe that
Oswald was a lone assassinator so this
is a major step you got to reject the
old in order to open up people's mind so
I think they have to hear it so people
who are in a position to influence
others should do it and in my case I
never saw myself as do
this I didn't I didn't have a degree in
economics and I didn't teach in a
university and and I didn't have access
but all of a sudden it's opened up and I
couldn't believe it I it surprised me
but you know one thing that came out of
my two campaigns is the young Americans
for liberty are you familiar with that
group yal they have I can't remember I
can't keep up with hundreds and hundreds
of chapters around the country that's
changing people I believe that and they
are also I believe pretty political too
they are supporting certain candidates
and they are winning some of these races
that but they they've done this right
because the ideas have to change then
you have to do it then you have to get
the supporters one thing that I also
liked in Washington because I knew how
much of a minority I was many members
would come to me and they would like
vote with me on a tough vote they say
Ron I'm a libertarian on this vote and I
never had anybody come and say you know
I can't do this or I'm gonna do this
because I'm a socialist they don't use
that that you started saying libertarian
freedom responsibility they wanted to
sort of appease me and say you know I'm
with you on this for good reasons so
that happened you know toward the end of
the time I was in Washington and I think
that's all positive what I see on the
campuses interchange in a philosophy
very very positive you create a movement
with a lot of a young generation that's
just all over the place you see them I
mean you go to I go places and I see and
the Fed and defend in offices everywhere
that just means a lot of younger people
are reading the content that makes them
question things that's been conventional
for a while which surprises me a lot is
you know I've said a lot of things what
I'm worried about yeah this too much dad
too much war and all this and probably
if I speak to a group for an hour maybe
about 45 minutes will be these are your
problems they're all yours you have a
lot of debt and look at the fan look at
all this and then I talk about why and
why things are moving directly and
people will have to say you know I like
what you're saying because you're such
an OPS and this well that's good but you
know I was saying a lot of things to
worry about but they want to hear an
answer and they love to hear the
positive some
politicians are able to do that you know
make America great again I sort of think
I fit into that category but a
completely different different
definition from Barney Sanders or Donald
Trump he said nice things about Sanders
before you've said really nice things
about Z and this goes back to the non
partisan stuff some of these some of the
stuff that Sanders which would say agree
on foreign policy we supported same
bills and anti corporate Azure versus
and but when it comes to drugs Trump
wants to put them all in jail you're not
for them so let me ask you who do you
like like who have who's ever been a
candidate where you've said this guy is
a candidate if I were to campaign and
support somebody I feel this candidates
a solid candidate and it can be you well
I guess I guess it would be self-serving
if I mention the family so that people
would write there's also a little bit
for the right than you are though Rand
is a little bit further right than you
are I know he's your son but he seems
nobody can't have the same approach that
I have I mean everybody's gonna vary
because I think you're an anomaly I
think you are an anomaly so when you cut
what are you gonna do with me no idea
how bad I every single time he says
something send it tweet at Ron Paul
we're gonna put the correct one here and
Patrick Padilla can i name my website
sure because I do a daily program I
don't have the numbers that you have I
mean well I I do a daily program and
it's a streamlines Ron Paul Liberty
report calm by the way you know what be
very interesting seriously this would be
very interesting if it was me you Snoop
Dogg in the same room together and you
talked about marijuana you know why let
me explain to you why this is why 88
percent of African Americans vote
Democratic you know this I know this it
used to be 60 percent 64 percent back in
1960 before Goldwater you were around to
kind of see what happened with that
transition there today it's 88 percent
it used to be 94 percent I think if your
message gets to I'm Middle Eastern most
of our you know people don't listen to
your views and what you're saying except
when you're on a national stage
if Middle Eastern Hispanics African
Americans many minorities heard that
message I think you can spark a certain
mindset into minorities that maybe they
haven't had before
you know they we've done a little bit of
polling on this just by which groups are
most anti-war which I'm strongly yeah I
don't like of course he's unnecessary
war the Hispanics are very very anti-war
whether those statistics are reliable or
not but it was fascinating it was
probably done you know in my district
you know a poll I told Charlie Couric I
said Charlie too many people that you
guys are talking with these concepts are
white too many I was at his conference
he had thousand people there five
percent were non-white I said we need
more we need more not just younger
Millennials and Gen Xers we need
minorities to hear this argument
currently 66 percent of Hispanics vote
Democrat eighty eight percent of African
American you know the big the big
problem in politics for myself would be
all right I'm talking to a minority
group and what are you gonna do for us I
said I don't deal in that way because I
don't want to deal with you as a group
you're not important because you belong
to a group you're important because
you're an individual and an individual
should be treated the same way it's
important for me to have data to know
what my center shoots free-throw wise
for me to be able to go and address an
enlighten that community I think you
have a lot to offer dead serious and I
think the part that you can influence is
the younger minority non-white in
America I really believe and we're doing
pretty well on our yal conferences on
campuses okay we will get them and no
worries out very clear so IRS talked
about the IRS because they didn't have
it
we shouldn't have an IRS now today's tax
code is a little over 74,000 pages back
and when he got started I think even
1913 one Federal Reserve got started
December 23 1913 our tax code was run
thirteen to twenty pages give or take
right today seventy four thousand what
do you think about it well I think if
you endorse that principle and most
people accept it because they think
they're going to get something back but
the whole thing is if they accept the
principle what you're accepting is that
the government owns you self ownership
as part of the lubrication you accept
what well income tax there's two things
that shows that you let the government
own you and that is the income tax
because if you make your ten million
dollars this year the government wants
to come and take four or five million
oh I thought it was my money no the
government has the right to keep
whatever it was hey have a total control
of your income and they give you
permission on how much you can keep so
you've lost your ownership because the
harder you work you know if there's more
socialism the less you're going to get
so you've sacrificed yourself ownership
and the other thing is if you endorse
the military draft if you say the
government can come anytime they want
and I lived through and I was in the
service in the 60s the tragedy of
Vietnam I mean we lost 60,000 men and
what for insanity bad ideas and that
that meant that the government I had a
school teacher that had been in World
War two he was drafted in in Korea
before Vietnam he got killed over there
for what you know now we've had all
those years over there prohibiting
Koreans to talk to each other
that was our policy we never let the
South go to the north and that's why I
love what's going on now in in Korea
because it's the leaders the people of
South Korea elected to god has said we
ought to talk to the people in the north
and that's wonderful which you should
let that happen you know what let the
people solve their problems let the
people individuals solve their problems
and get rid of the IRS so if we get rid
of yaris what should it be sure to be
just a flat tax I don't want them to tax
your income at all we didn't have until
1913 we did pretty well we had a lot of
economic growth our biggest growth
period was in a 19th century you want
everything to be private for the most
part well I guess there's a few things
that we have to do but I mean the goal
might be out there that it could work
but as we're along so far away from that
we have to have a judicial system but
there it's a rotten system I mean I
think the judicial system is so unfair
how about enforcing the drug laws look
how biased it is against minorities so
the judicial system is corrupt and look
at all this baloney going on with Russia
gay people want to build this hostility
toward Russia they'll lie and say
anything they can they'll corrupt their
justice system we've heard so many lies
and innuendoes on who did what
this whole thing and it's gonna be all
the accusers of Trump doing these evil
things with Russia are the ones who were
doing it themselves it's right that
that's the judicial system it's a rotten
system so but equal justice under the
laws or what we should be dealing with
but there's too many laws there's way
too many lost too many prisons we have
more prisoners than any other country in
the world because we have too many laws
and we need a lot less laws and if you
have infractions they should be done
locally so you so you probably like the
fact that the Trump is doing a lot of
the deregulation with whatever you I
think I think that has given some
euphoria to the markets has helped the
markets and the taxes helped him - the
more I listen to what you're saying or
your belief system fully possible to
happen in America or does it have to be
done with a new country that's getting
started with a constitution I think what
you're saying the Constitution has to be
kept and held and even some of the ways
I mean this stuff that you're talking
about are we so in too deep that there's
no way in the world we can work
backwards in those areas in many ways
that's true because they could you
campaign around that if you know there's
an there's no way in the world it's
gonna fall apart
you have to have something to replace it
with I I know so you're saying if it
falls apart we have some we know the
system is not viable or if you don't
think the system is viable we have this
nearly 22 trillion dollar debt 21
trillion dollars that they gave to the
Pentagon and they have an audit that
they don't know where it went so it's
gonna it's gonna fall apart so what are
you gonna replace it with is is the big
question it's like the deficit you say
well are you Ron gonna get a few more
people and why al is gonna help you
that's all good because of the messy but
will you get enough there where you
start winning the votes you won't win
very many votes there are too many
people totally dependent before I went
to Congress I used to think it was the
poor people you know too many people on
food stamps that's small compared to the
trillions and trillions of dollars who
owned a Federal Reserve in a banking
system now you have to get it to the
point where it will have to be done when
they bankruptcy is declared we will have
a bankruptcy the dollar will not
work and we will have to do something in
there lining up and I'm certain that
it's a non-viable system because it's
never been viable in 6000 years of
history where you can just run out
compute it used to be printing paper now
you just use a computer it doesn't work
I think it's a how it works out is it's
gonna be a it'll be different we don't
know how it would do I hope it doesn't
end like Venezuela but we had smart
before then become Venezuela that'd be a
whole different story yeah we're gonna
we're gonna have a rough time but the
only thing counts is how many people
will endorse the idea that Liberty is
better than authoritarianism for solving
our problems that's the only question
what should the role of government be in
a free society and you know it's no more
complex than that
and you say well you're too much about
perfection you're never gonna have it
probably two but at least at least you
know where you're going today nobody
knows where they're going in Washington
let me ask you do wait Trump leads when
you look at JFK Reagan and Lincoln
there's a couple things doe study had in
common politically maybe one is left one
is right but JFK probably today would
have been more independent than a
Democrat if he ran today JFK would have
been he wouldn't been today's Democrat
or the liberal that we have the one
thing that I saw with those three names
is they couldn't be controlled by money
they already yet they were not they were
true believers all three of them they
had very strong opinions and behind
closed doors they couldn't really be
pushed around that much
Kennedy Reagan and Lincoln at least
that's what happens when I study history
and I see some of that here would Trump
do you think that Trump is pushing the
envelope a little too much are you happy
with the way he's going sometimes you
know we mentioned regulations I think
less regulations is good and I think
less taxes is good so in that sense I
I'm glad that he flip-flop on Korea so
when he flip-flops sometimes I'll give
him credit that's what my program does
when he does think it's like that I do
it every I'm try to say very independent
but when he treats around like they're
doing you know and say well what I
advise now is nobody should buy one
of gas from her on I don't I don't like
that because I believe trade is good you
know that's what we want we should be
trading with Cuba so he doesn't have a
basic principle even though he has some
libertarian instincts
he's an interventionist and he's very
much of an authoritarian and that's not
a good place to have an authoritarian
because the executive branch in this
government has way too much power they
can start wars they're getting ready to
have another Authority use military
force passing to Congress which means
we're going to have perpetual war
against any country in the world and
right now you know we're bombing 60 or
70 countries we're in a hundred and
twenty countries that's all going to end
in to me I think that would be a
blessing that would be a blessing you
know if we could talk to the Chinese and
the Soviets when they were pretty
monstrous it was a benefit at least the
Cold War ended you know and we weren't
threatening us but now some people liked
it well that's not good for business we
need to sell more weapon so we need to
stir up trouble it's those Russians
they've caused all the trouble I don't I
don't quite buy into that so on the
Border's side yourself with all the
talks right now with border where do you
stand because libertarians they're 50/50
on border you hear some people saying
well you know should be open border it's
about liberty and some say no we need to
leave it to the state no should be
federal level what do you think about
border in my book Liberty define I have
a chapter in there about borders and I
think what you do is you have to remove
the incentive you know if you subsidize
something you get more of it so if an
individual can come in and barge in and
to me it's similar to barging in your
house nobody wants them barging in your
house but barging into our country is
like our house because we have to pay
for it you know
so they barge in and they do end up
getting into our schools and and medical
care and they get an easy road to
citizenship that shouldn't be you know
we shouldn't do it so if they weren't
rewarded they wouldn't be doing this and
it's just too bad that some of the some
of the messages in South Central America
we've been involved in Central America
many years you know interfering you know
most recent Columbia because it was
drugs and different things like that and
there's a lot of poverty
we'd have done much better off if we
would have had
a private group inviting people up here
and teaching them Austrian economics
teasing on what free markets all about
that's what they need and they don't
need just more dollars what's
unfortunate is what we offer most
countries is you know if you come our
way and do what we tell you we're gonna
give you money if you don't we're gonna
bomb you and if you mess around on
wanting to get rid of the dollar as your
reserve currency we don't like that
we'll get rid of you and look at what
happened in Iraq and Libya you know and
and Assad was too independent was that a
Republican saying Assad had to go that
was Obama the peace can hey that's why
yeah similar to another president like
Carter who kind of influenced a shot to
be gone in Iran as well there was a lot
of influence there as well with the
connection I was like hey you know
Iran's have a little too much power and
they're coming up and they're about to
pass UK and all this other stuff well we
can have Iran have too much control and
then we saw what happened with that
afterwards half a million people died
when a war started between Iran and Iraq
fair enough that that's interesting with
the borders
how about education your big supporter
of changing the entire educational
system you're now in the same page with
that I wrote a book called drop out and
get school because I'm not a very big
fan of the current education system at
all so I think a lot and and the stat I
was reading about what's a follow and I
want to know what you think about this
so currently today you're a big
supporter of homeschooling which is
about three to four percent today's
homeschooling right private school used
to be 11.2% I think it's dropped off to
nine point seven percent and then the
rest public is 86 percent okay is what
we currently are those are the ratios we
have currently today what direction
would you like to see that take place in
the future
well my program the Ron Paul curriculum
is homeschooling you say three four
percent it's you know to change a
country's attitude you don't have to
think in terms of majority you don't
have to say boy Ron you have to convert
51% of the people notice you said 20%
that was another I think I think eight
eight percent or so of people who think
about these things if they're speaking
the right message and they're in the
right places they can influence it
because you know even when when our home
revolution occurred the average person
was sort of you could criticize some of
them
because they they were ambivalent about
what was going on but the leaders they
were very very philosophic and they knew
where they they were coming from but
they were definitely less than they 10%
of the population maybe there's seven or
eight percent so that's why there should
never be discouraged now how are you
ever going to convert people
so actually we sort of offer our courses
to people who who want to be involved in
promoting ideas and promoting the
libertarian philosophy you're
recommending parents take charge your
kids don't let the government manipulate
your kids or brainwash your kids
whatever Ward is take control take the
responsibility start teaching your kids
the right things is that kind of where
your that is it and I think that's we
should be very encouraged by that do you
think parents are afraid of doing that
do you think parents are I'm wondering I
don't know if I can do it or do you
think we're just lazy it wears a lot
there's a lot of that okay I wonder
whether I have been patient enough and
always busy delivering babies for some
people but there's the answers to that
there is a private schooling and maybe
five families could get together all
kinds of things I could adapt you think
a four-year degree today has as much
influence as it once used to have like
hey you know you don't have a four-year
degree I don't know if anyone's gonna
hire you in the free marketplace do you
think it has that much influence today
as I did 30 years ago do to do in
certain areas in essence I think if you
want to go to a big firm you gotta have
credentials for law firms and even
business they want you have a master's
degree but the average person you know
somebody who's asked me what would
you've done if you didn't get into
medical school I said looking back I
probably would have said I think I'll be
a plumber I think I'm gonna go out and
I'm gonna be the best plumber in the
world because I don't have to go to
college to learn how to be a plumber
yeah that's sort of say it's pretty yeah
or be a salesperson entrepreneur a lot
of that stuff you can do it but I think
when it's specialized engineer doctor
lawyer yeah I have the degrees and we
have four grandchildren that are in
medicine three of out of our five of em
days and then there's four grandchildren
you're building a team that's exciting
I'm still at six for two-year old I
still have little babies I'm Way I'm
just a startup so so okay so we talked
about that with education would you
support a you know
Mark Cuban's a big and ran guy big I was
sitting with mark you and I give him an
original sleeve original cover Atlas
Shrugged whom it was very pleased he had
never had something like that before
would you support a few ran out and says
I'm gonna run for president will run as
a libertarian would you support some
other lucky Jimmy do you think that
would be good
III don't know his views well enough it
would be sort of like when Trump started
running I have no idea what his views
were I just don't know it's gonna be
built somebody asked me by something I
said
as of today mark I have I'm not madam
man right now the only contest would be
how good is your tweeting he's actually
pretty good Trump's an entertainer yes
what human is trying to become an
entertainers where he owns a sports team
shark tank is there anybody out today
said if he threw his hat in there I'd
support him like I know Schiff was a
former economic adviser to you if he ran
which is supported are you a fan of what
McAfee is saying consider himself as a
you know libertarian cybersecurity guy
because that's the biggest threat we
have in America is there any names that
you actually would like one that pops up
and I would know all his beliefs I'd
want to talk to him and I might dismiss
a fraud but there would be some like in
Congress if my son ever ran again you
know there's other like Thomas Massie
and Justin Amash these are real good
voters but there's only under
fortunately about a handful of them you
know so there there were you akira
johnson guy had read some stuff that you
were not a gary johnson no I didn't
think he was because if there's any one
place that you better be as pure as you
can is when you're trying to set a
standard you don't have the license in a
in a third party you wouldn't want a
socialist running and saying what I
really wanted is to build GM or
something like that yeah you are more
for when the Kelantan one market
collapse happen let GM go out of
business that's where you are more
that's what's supposed to ya if they
mess up they mess up otherwise you know
the people who get bailed out are the
ones who have to buy influence and
that's the system we still have yes but
what I'm saying it's gonna end you're
saying it's the bankruptcy so much like
the 21 trillion dollar debt that we have
you're not including all the unpaid
commitments that we have with Medicare
health care all
200 that's over 200 that's against 200
trillion dollars that's a scary number
by the way that is a scary number
especially with the fact that we are
living longer so that could be even
imagine I'm scare a lot of people into
looking into our philosophy so here's
what I would say I was in Greece four
days ago
okay I was in Greece four days ago in
Athens and we held a meeting and one guy
showed up honest I'm gonna say Panos
because there's a million pounds in
Athens so Panos like st. John so it's
not you know trying to pinpoint so they
come together and say Pat what can we do
to change the economical system here in
Greece I said you guys ought to go out
there start the biggest revolution with
young entrepreneurs talking about
capitalism and start studying the
concepts that helps you all these great
minds that were raised in Athens and you
know Greece you ought to be inspired by
some of these people so my suggestion to
anybody that's not even in America but
if you're not in America you're all over
the place
I suggest go buy all his books literally
start with Liberty define it's good you
know book you have about revolution
about what the educational system and
the fair I think it's fantastic book but
go one by one by one with the books he's
written and study its content I think 50
years from now a hundred years from now
people are gonna consider the man
sitting to my right they don't have to
agree I don't sit here and just I don't
know if I agree with that I don't know
if I agree with this but the point is
everything's going to basic fundamentals
that challenge all sides of politics and
I think that's very healthy for your
processing to become better in politics
it makes you question everything because
initially especially when I said we got
three people here that are libertarian
maybe one is socialism I was being
sarcastic first thing you said was what
that's good because someone's gonna make
our arguments get better that was his
immediate answer having an opposition so
I suggest you go read his books I
suggest you follow some of his content
you do have YouTube channel yourself as
well I noticed that and if you watch
this again anything you heard especially
quantitative easing quantitative easing
anything we heard today that was of
interest to your questions send me a
tweet sent a tweet Adam I'm really
curious to know what you took away from
today's episode and would that being
said dr. Rampal thank you so much truly
enjoyed you very much really enjoy nice
thanks for watching everybody by the way
be sure to subscribe
take care guys
by